I can summarize my life by the saying to  God your plans evil laugh at you because  anything I planned never really happened  and I've thought I wanted well the  things I thought I wanted back in my 20s  or 30s  did manifest and I'm glad I didn't FS  because the real estate was not coming  from our true selves anyway but meant  for my own conditioning wounds a lot of  people when we grow up in culture and  conditioning and program and have  desires and wants and needs they're not  even their own but programmed into them  right and there's a soul calling for  something else and we can call it soul  purpose or what not right so it's about  this alignment getting yourself out of  the way which is either said than done  but that's the whole part of a field of  esoteric work right to become a  conscious transducer fire energy is the  divine of what whatever you may want to  call it let's stay on this for a little  bit